zack snyder's justice league has a lot
going on in its four-hour run time so
it's not surprising if you miss a few
things while watching it
these lines go by quickly but they're
surprisingly loaded with meanie
here are some of the key quotes from
zack snyder's justice league
i have come to enlighten you to the
great
darkness i will bathe
in your fear most people would be
intimidated by the sight of a phalanx of
battle heart and amazonian warriors but
that's not the case for steppenwolf
when darkseid's lieutenant breaches the
stronghold on themyscira he doesn't
cower in fear
he taunts hippolyta and her soldiers
before unleashing a horde of parrot
demons on the vigilant defenders
a few minutes later steppenwolf repeats
himself the great
darkness begins if you're a long time dc
comics fan your ears probably perked up
immediately
published in 1982 the great darkness
saga was a five part story line that
started in legion of superheroes number
290. the story pits a team called the
legion
a group of 30th century youths who have
modeled themselves after present-day
superheroes like superman
against a mysterious villain called the
master and one of the all-time greatest
reveals in superhero comics the legion
eventually learns that the master is
none other than darkseid who has been
waiting for a thousand years for the
opportunity to strike
to this day the great darkness saga is
still considered the very best legion of
superheroes tale and one of darkseid's
most memorable appearances
it's only fitting that it gets a nod in
darkseid's feature film debut
wonder woman
what do you think man you think she'd
ever go for a younger guy
barry allen's offhand casually pervy
quip to cyborg isn't all that notable on
its own although cyborg's reply
is one of the snyder cuts more memorable
jokes she's 5 000 years old barry
every guy's a younger guy surprisingly
this little exchange marks a big moment
in the history of the dc dceu
it's the very first time in any of these
movies that diana is actually called
wonder woman on screen
seriously she doesn't get called by her
superhero nickname in batman vs superman
dawn of justice the justice league
theatrical cut or in either of her solo
films
in the comics of course diana has been
going by wonder woman since her mother
bestowed the title on her in her debut
story which appeared in 1941's all-star
comics number eight
in her next appearance 1942 sensation
comics number one
shortly after landing in man's world
diana causes a big scene as she outruns
cars beats up muggers and flex bullets
with her magic bracelets
this attracts the attention of an agent
named al kale who signs diana up for a
stage show
it's a hit and the newspapers soon dub
her wonder woman publicly
diana's partnership with kale ends just
a few pages later when diana quits the
show and kayle tries to run off with the
profits
still by that point she's stuck with the
name suppose we start with your name
wonder woman sure but i'm happy to
discuss with you in any way like why you
sent to boywonder
to do a man's job there's a very good
reason why we don't see batman's trusty
sidekick robin in zack snyder's justice
league
he's been dead for years before the
snyder cut however all we had were
oblique hints to that effect like the
robin suit memorial in the batcave and
comments from snyder during promotional
interviews
now thanks to batman's heated exchange
with the joker robin's death at the
hands of the clown prince of crime is
explicitly snyder vs canon
of course joker killing robin isn't
exactly a new idea
it's been done a number of times
including in frank miller's the dark
knight returns
which was a huge influence for zack
snyder's justice league the most notable
example however occurs in the 80s
storyline of death in the family which
somehow ends up being even more morose
than snyder's take
in batman number 427 the second
installment of the story the joker beats
jason todd's robin with a crowbar then
blows up a building with robin still
inside
that's a huge cliffhanger but it gets
even worse rather than letting writer
jim starlin decide robin's fate
dc comics set up a 1 900 number hotline
which readers could call to decide
whether robin lived or died
death won by a poultry 72 votes sealing
the boy wonder's fate
you have the blood of the old gods in
you
steppenwolf's half-taunting
half-admiring observation during his
first real showdown with wonder woman
begs a question
if zeus aries and the rest are the old
gods who are the new ones
well comic readers already know the
answer see darkseid steppenwolf desaad
and the rest made their debut in the
fourth world saga which introduced the
new gods to dc continuity courtesy of
master comic book artist jack kirby
the fourth world is jack kirby at his
biggest and most imaginative and tells
the story of a cosmic battle between the
forces of good and evil
on one side are the residents of the
planet new genesis which is led by
highfather and his adopted son orion
on the other you have the forces of
darkseid who resides on the planet
apocalypse
kirby never really got to finish the
story which was maybe more ambitious
than entirely coherent
still many of the new gods characters
became fixtures of dc's canon
so it's nice to see steppenwolf pay
subtle tribute to the story that started
it all
ship's all yours now kid you're the boss
[Music]
ryan shore director of nanotechnology
that's your thing ryan choi spends most
of zack snyder's justice league playing
second fiddle to star labs director
silas stone but the end of the movie
sets him up for much bigger
or should we say smaller things in light
of silas's sacrifice ryan gets a much
deserved promotion but as this line
hints that's only the beginning for the
scientist
see in the comics ryan choi is better
known as the atom a superhero with the
power to change size at will
hence the whole nanotechnology thing
choi is actually the fourth superhero to
take on the mantle of the atom
following the golden ages al pratt ray
palmer and former suicide squad
recruit adam cray he's also inexorably
tied to the adam's legacy
in the comics troy takes over ray
palmer's position at ivy university
after the superhero goes missing
leading him to palmer's old bio belt
which harnesses the power of a miniature
white dwarf star in order to give its
wearer size changing abilities
the words that echo through clark kent's
head as he reclaims his superhero
identity or throwback to man of steel
during which russell crowe's jor
l delivers a heartfelt speech to his son
while superman flies for the first time
it's more than that though it's also a
reference to all-star superman by grant
morrison and frank whiteley one of the
very best superman comics ever published
published in 2006 all star superman is a
streamlined continuity free take on the
man of steel that aims to tell timeless
superman stories revolving around a
simple concept
thanks to lex luthor's machination
superman's powers become overcharged by
solar radiation he's never been more
powerful
he's also dying with only a year left to
live superman spends his remaining time
on earth doing what he always does
working to make it a better place still
even the man of steel has limits
eventually solar radiation poisoning
catches up with superman and he begins
to pass
that's when he encounters a memory of
his father jor-el who delivers these
same poignant words
they're not much but they're enough
superman rallies and boils luther's
schemes
then literally ventures into the center
of the sun which he keeps burning for
all of eternity
jor-el's speech is already a perfect
summation of superman's entire deal but
it becomes even more poignant given its
placement in zack snyder's justice
league as in the comic it comes at the
moment when superman treading the line
between life and death rededicates
himself to his original mission and
truly becomes the savior he was always
meant to be
as a tribute to one of the most popular
superman stories ever told
it couldn't be better i hate atlanteans
as much as you amazons do
zack snyder's justice league establishes
a long-standing rivalry between the
atlanteans and the amazons
while it never quite pays off it does
give wonder woman and aquaman a bit of
history together as she explains in the
movie the two peoples once even went to
war with each other
the idea of a long-standing rivalry
between atlantis and themyscira has come
up a number of times
the atlantean amazonian war is one of
the centerpieces of dc's big flashpoint
event in which barry allen creates an
alternate timeline by traveling to the
past to save his mother
in that version of the timeline a war
begins when wonder woman's mother
hippolyta is assassinated on wonder
woman and aquaman's wedding day
sparking a conflict that sees the
amazons conquer britain while the
atlanteans sink most of western europe
as in zack snyder's justice league
however the two sides ultimately reach
an understanding putting their
differences aside to stop an unhinged
thomas
wayne who serves as this reality's
batman it's not quite the same as in the
movie but at the very least you can see
where zack snyder got the idea
who have you ever loved
while we'll never get to see zack
snyder's proposed justice league sequels
we know the basic outline of what they
were going to be about thanks largely to
the dialogue and the snyder cuts
extended epilogue
it all begins when mira snaps at batman
after he tries to console her about
aquaman's death
and to be fair it's kind of
inappropriate after all losing loved
ones is kind of batman's whole thing
as the joker explains he knows exactly
what it's like to lose someone he loves
you know like a father
like a mother like an adopted son
there's one person who's very
conspicuous in her absence on the
joker's list though
lois lane yep that's right as zack
snyder explained in his justice league
follow-ups we were going to learn that
bruce wayne had fallen for superman's
girlfriend
making her death in the nightmare
timeline all the more tragic to the dark
knight
you'll never love anybody the way that i
love your son
making it even worse her death which
caused superman to break bad is batman's
fault
how many alternate timelines do you
destroy the world because
frankly you don't have the colonies to
die yourself
ironically however this line also hints
at how batman was going to save things
this is just an alternate timeline in
snyder's planned trilogy the main one
would be saved after cyborg used the
mother boxes to send flash back in time
making sure that batman died instead of
lois and keeping superman on the side of
good
basically snyder's whole justice league
trilogy is here in this one scene
it's just hidden in the dialogue how did
you get the house back from the bank
i bought the bank
[Music]
congratulations by the way batman and
superman has spent most of their time in
the dc
eu as enemies their first clash was so
epic it lasted for an entire movie the
second while much shorter came right
after superman had been resurrected and
his mind was still on the fritz
however by the end of zack snyder's
justice league the two are not just
colleagues but friends
still when bruce slaps clark on the back
and congratulates him it's not
immediately clear why
it's not for coming back to life bruce
and the rest of the justice league did
that
it's not for getting the family farm
back either bruce did that too
it could be because of his engagement to
lois lane but the more likely answer
lies in a few small details you might
have missed
earlier in the movie you can spot a
pregnancy test in lois lane's drawer
when the scene begins lois carries a
bassinet into the kent's farmhouse
between those two clues the conclusion
is obvious lois lane is pregnant and a
super baby is on the way
well kind of super as snyder has
explained his original plan was for lois
and clark's baby to be powerless
although he'd later take after his uncle
bruce's example and strap on a cowl to
become gotham's new batman
the snyder cuts most memorable line
isn't actually in the movie it only
appears in one of the trailers
we live in a society where honor
a distant memory if you're not
perpetually online you may not have
known what all the fuss was about
for the rest of us though it was a
moment to remember while that phrase
originated as a line on the classic
sitcom seinfeld it became associated
with the joker thanks to memes
surrounding 2019's joker starring
joaquin phoenix
as time has gone on it's become even
more popular given that the snyder cuts
is basically a four hour piece of fan
service anyway people went rabid when it
looked like it was going to make its way
into the movie
while the line didn't make the final cut
zack snyder still talked to the press
about it and he says the memification of
the snyder cuts was an ad-lib so that
buzzworthy trailer moment was basically
jared leto's fault
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more
looper videos about the dc extended
universe are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one